le problème est de savoir si
politiquement les bons choix sont faits
reconnaître des failles et des ratés il
y était obligé puisque de fait tous les
français s'en sont rendu compte et ils
se sont même rendus compte qu'il y avait
un mensonge sur la question des masques
c'est pas seulement des failles et des
rapts et c'est des mensonges pour
habiter pour habiller des failles et des
ratés qui ne relèvent pas seulement des
manuels macron mais qui relève du
gouvernement précédent de celui de
françois hollande et de jean marc
ayrault
alors simplement les français auraient
sans doute préféré qu'on leur parle
comme à des adultes et il va falloir
aller encore plus loin dans cette façon
de parler aux citoyens comme à des
adultes et de leur faire confiance sur
leur capacité à s'adapter et à juger sur
la question des tests j insiste il faut
être beaucoup plus clair dire à quel
moment où il envisage d'avoir
suffisamment de tests pour pouvoir
tester l'ensemble de la population dans
une maladie où la plupart des gens n'ont
pas de symptômes
et donc si on attend qu'ils aient des
symptômes pour les tester ils ont eu le
temps de répandre le virus à peu près
partout la sécurité dépend aussi de la
fiabilité du discours politique
[Musique]
première chose que l'on peut dire c'est
que emmanuel macron a été concret à
apporter des réponses sur l'organisation
ce qui permet aux français de savoir à
quoi s'attendre après il n'a pas répondu
aux questions essentielles qui
permettent de discuter de ce qui va se
passer parce que la question c'est pas
seulement celle de savoir si nous allons
sortir et quand nous allons sortir accès
la question des tests et des masques qui
permettent d'être en sécurité
alors il explique à un moment de son
allocution que le port du masque pourra
être systématique dans les transports ça
c'est pas clair je verrai à aucun moment
il ne revient sur ce mensonge qui était
que les masques ne servait à rien il va
falloir pendant le mois qui vient être
un petit peu plus clair sur la nécessité
que tout le monde porte des masques sur
les tests c'est la même chose
les français ont besoin de savoir de
combien de test on dispose
comment ils seront mis en oeuvre or là
pour l'instant
le président continuent à dire on ne va
pas testé tout le monde ça ne servirait
à rien mais si ça sert à rien pourquoi
l'allemagne le fait l'allemagne qui s'en
sort beaucoup mieux que nous ne
recommençons pas cette erreur qui
consiste à habiller la pénurie par un
discours qui serait un discours faut il
va falloir aller un petit peu plus loin
dans la vérité des choses tout
simplement pour que chacun puisse se
dire quand il reviendra à sa vie à peu
près normale qui ne sera pas la vie
normale d'avant et bien au moins le
minimum de sécurité sera respectée
[Musique]
heureux les convertis tant mieux on ne
va pas lui en vouloir d'avoir compris
que son modèle était absolument
catastrophique dans un dans un moment de
crise comme celui ci encore une fois il
y a les mots et sur les mots on est ravi
que beaucoup de gens il n'est pas les
manuels mâcon n'est pas le seul 1 depuis
ces derniers jours le nombre de
personnes qui s'aperçoivent que tu étais
que c'est absolument catastrophique de
ne pas fabriquer les médicaments en
france c'est quelque chose
d'extraordinaire mais pendant des années
quand on expliqué qu'il y avait des
filières stratégiques on se ferait et je
faisais rire au nez
donc aujourd'hui nous avons tous compris
que l'indépendance moque emmanuel macron
a repris hier soir comme il a repris le
mot de souveraineté l'indépendance c'est
essentiel parce que c'est une protection
des citoyens
simplement une fois qu'on a dit ça il
faut mettre en oeuvre c'est ça nécessite
de faire des choix ça nécessite d'être
extrêmement rigoureux et ça nécessite de
fâcher quelques intérêts divers donc on
verra bien au pied du mur où en sera le
masson
[Musique]